they had this is done originally on a
college campus so they had male and
female members of the experimental team
who were judged to be moderately
attractive walk up to members of the
opposite sex on a college campus and say
hi I've been noticing around campus
lately I find you very attracted would
you and ask them one of three questions
would you go on a date with me
uh would you come back to my apartment
with me
would you have sex with me and they
simply recorded the percentage of
individuals who agreed to these three
different requests and of the women
approached about 50 percent agreed to go
out on a date with the guy six percent
agreed to go back to his apartment and
zero percent agreed to have sex of
course um women typically needed a
little more information about the guy of
of the man approached by the female
Confederate also about 50 percent agreed
to go on a date with her 69 percent
agreed to go back to her apartment and
75 percent would have sex with her
you're a man how do you answer yes I'll
just go back and have sex with you let's
just start there let's start there